so as the fact-finding review takes
place protesters were outside making
sure that their cries for justice for
jorge gomez were heard
eight news now reporter victoria saha
joins us now live with reaction
denise it was a peaceful protest but
emotional as their cries for justice
were loud and clear
[Music]
that was a common chant we kept hearing
today protesters still upset about gomez
being shot
19 times by four metro police officers
because they believe he was running away
from police
ten months later they want all four
officers involved in the death of gomez
to be charged
after the hearing gomez's mom clearly
emotional
addressed the crowd wanting everyone to
know her son did not do anything wrong
by running from police as he was being
shot with bean bag rounds
if someone's hitting me with pepper
bones i'm going to run
it's human nature it's fight or flight
did he stand there in a fight
no he ran away what did they do
they hit him twice in the head four
times in the back
two tides in the left side he falls away
for these officers
never did he touch a weapon
his mom also continued to say gomez
would be proud of the turnaround of
today's events because this is exactly
what he was fighting for
when he was killed now the family's
attorney did say that they will still
continue their lawsuit against
metro police no matter what happens
reporting live victoria saha
8 news now